winter's coming a little late in my case
but here we go anyway like most geeks I
love Game of Thrones however unlike some
of you I do not have HBO nor do I use on
demand which means I've gotten to see
season 3's finally now it's out on
blu-ray this seems like a great
opportunity for me to review this as I
see it episode by episode I am gonna be
doing as best as I can to keep these
spoiled of freedom I am gonna be talking
very openly and very freely about the
first two seasons but come on I should
also point out that I have not read the
song of fire ice books nor do I intend
to read the books or at least I'm not
gonna read them to the point that I get
ahead of where the show is I have
learned from experience that when you
read a book before you see the
adaptation whether it's TV or film
you're just setting yourself up for
disappointment it's one thing if you've
already read the source material but if
you rush just to read it all you're
gonna do is realize how much better it
could have been I would rather enjoy the
TV show as it is then go back and read
the book and go oh wow there's all this
other awesome stuff they didn't use so
here we go season three series premiere
Valar do dar have died hey valor - hey
knee
yep episode 1 honestly coming out and I
was like that was kind of a low energy
start to this thing but when I think
about it first episodes in the seasons
have been kind of low-energy because
there's so much stuff that has to be
touched on just to get you up to speed
again before that you really start doing
anything so not a lot of story happens
in this first episode but that's kind of
okay there's still some great highlights
favorite here just for me Tyrion and
Bronn I would seriously watch a show
that is nothing but the two of these
guys they are so awesome together and
speaking of Tyrion how cool is it to
watch this scheming little bugger get
the complete Smackdown from his father
speaking of Tywin Lannister this seems
like you've got a place to talk about
how much I love the amount of power that
is put in the hands of what would
generally be considered elderly
characters usually when you've got older
people with power its power that they've
had for a long time and they're more
sort of monuments to what they used to
be and they're there for their wisdom I
don't know no no these guys have
raw pure power Tywin's probably the best
example but you also have the Lord
Commander of the Night Watch even Davos
The Onion Knight to a certain extent cuz
all these guys have inherent gravitas
and it's just wonderful to see it use so
effectively on the flip side of that
it's also really interesting to see the
characters who are losing their grips on
power a little bit Searcy is probably
the best example of this she's been on a
downward slope ever since the end of
season 1 when she realized that she is
not gonna be able to control Joffrey now
she's being outmaneuvered by his new
fiancee I didn't want to say though that
I think her drinking is being emphasized
a little bit too much no we get it
without her having a thing a wine in her
hand all the time also on the subject of
power loss is Joffrey himself he what
he's lost is not so much his power but
he certainly lost his confidence he's
realized at this point how precarious
his throne actually is which is
interesting it adds a new dynamic to him
he's still you still absolutely hate
this guy and you should but he's still
got a bit of dimension
Daenerys continues to be a bit of a
troublesome character for me she's
basically got two sides to her there's
the emerging leader who's got a real
sense of strength and then there's the
young almost girl who just is way in
over her head they're not blended
together very well they don't seem like
two aspects of the same person it feels
more like they flip her back and forth
between those two modes depending on
what any given scene calls for the other
thing about this episode that has me a
little bit torrent is they're continuing
to introduce more and more fantastical
and magical elements into the story
I love how casually a giant just turns
up and everybody's like oh yeah there's
a giant you didn't know if you're gonna
have it that's the best way to introduce
it but honestly I really love the
balance of the first season where there
were little hints of magic but we've
gotten more and more stuff we've gotten
the warlocks and the woman in red and
really she was the turning point when
she gave birth to that shadow demon in
the second season as much as that was a
fantastic holy crap moment it was sort
of the start of Magic becoming more and
more prominent and to me it actually
makes the whole thing feel a little bit
less special because it's just adopting
more and more kind of Jeanette
a fantasy element I know it seems like
I'm complaining a bit about this episode
I like it but it's just the things that
have been bugging me a little bit across
the course of the show they really now
is becoming clear there's they're here
to stay they're not going anywhere but
this was still a good solid episode and
it really feels like good foundation
building I'll be back with the next
episode as soon as I see it in the
meantime is there any aspect of the show
that you kind of wish out that one thing
I think they just drop that whatever it
is leave a comment let's talk about it
and until then this council is adjourned